comme on a toujours un temps de retard
dans tpm pays on va faire la grille est
aujourd'hui puisque steyer rio-paris et
benji mettait pas les liens exacts il y
a des galettes
je vous le dis c'est très simple c'est
le jeu de la galette il y a neuf galette
s il y a deux chefs
il y à une fève doury il fera gagner un
magnifique cadeau à une personne autour
de la table plus un tweet hausse c'est
un vélo bécane électrique pliable alors
exactement passé benhaim qu'en fait
c'est le leader c'est l'examen ce cas
c'est le leader du vélo électrique
français est celui qui tombera sur la
fève noir gagnera une belle race rats il
devra se déguiser en sheila allée dans
le bureau du directeur des programmes de
ses 8 euros du bacon pour chanter sur la
table deux soeurs sur son bureau les
rois mages
m
[Musique]
aie aie aie aie c'est toi qui viens
d'arriver je choisis ta part de 1 à 9
je m'élève non non je vais te l'emmener
à paris merci beaucoup sirène la
politesse sa motion ça me chante et ça
me change à liège femmes associent ici
me dit merci beaucoup personnes étudiées
vas-y connard personnes police et une
allemande et un harnais aux personnes
poli dans l'émission les gens la
regardent un truc de fou je suis alors
moi je t'explique ringarde mon fils est
né le 7 aujourd'hui nous sommes le 7 et
un choc du cheval à 9
c'est très important pour moi pour le
choisir le sait pas procès tebben tall
qu est page et la bouffe et non non non
pas maintenant l'année la manche y était
pas appris la presse
mais là je voulais le 7 septembre soit
la m
quoique j'ai deux heures je vais prendre
l'a5 tram ça c'est très bon signe a un
truc
prénom nom agissait bel abbès choc
isabelle hayeur kelly l'a 9 s'il vous
plaît j'ai fait des filles bien sûr a
bien sûr j'aurais aimé quand je suis
dans une forme allégée radine j'arrive à
vous dans un instant rien entendu vous
êtes mobile une la 9e
malheureusement kelly lacunes par deux
et que ça saute
et que ça saute et que ça saute en asie
rapide quassam ce rapide merci je vous
rappelle qu'il ya de fèves une fève noir
une fête daury allait vraiment là trois
chefs la 3 maxime l'a8 l'a8 taylor très
bien on a eu nos trois coups russie
n'est pas choisir leur donne ses
meilleurs pas quoi qu'il ait pas
chauffer aller danser meilleur d'accord
mais la galette la chauffer un peu sur
moi tu vois que tu as la flûte enchantée
jean-michel l'a6 et enfin castaldi mal à
4 ans évidemment le de la dernière page
attention je vous rappelle il était de
noir et il y a une faible durée y est
c'est très simple celui qui aura la fef
doré gagnera un magnifique cadeau on
sait pas encore ce que c'est si l on ne
sait pas ce que c'est est ce que
quelqu'un est au sommet alors elle veut
bouffer la galette de minutes et on a
les pattes
est ce que quelqu'un veut changer sa
galette à moi moi je veux bien toi tu
veux bien mais aussi va bien je vais
bien je vais donner je vous dit rien a
qu'une qui peut changer sa gamme c'est
la nouvelle a dit m est ce que tu veux
changer ta galette tapas alors moi j'ai
pour principe d'être fidèle et loyal
donc je vais garder ce que j'ai choisi
cette c'est beau ouais bah écoutes je
vais te dire c'est pas grave
ayem fidèle et loyal oui tu n'as plus
rien à faire danser
[Applaudissements]
fidèle et loyal céder votre lopin il
fallait alors elle ne veut pas changer
mais ok je la galette d'ayem cinéma
dragon d'essence et magasins kohl dit
pour toi alors qu'au nom attendant
l'attention c'est fini mais quatre ça se
plaît à rappeler le nom de son mariage
de ses mains lors les séries chiffres tu
es celui attention les chéris quand il y
à une fève noir celui qui aura la fève
noir ira dans le bureau du patron pour
chanter comme les rois mages en galilée
je vous donnais 30 secondes pour manger
le plus de galles est possible et pour
me dire si j'avais la fed
ce sont-là fesses se dévoilent tout de
suite allez c'est parti vite les chiens
attention bien la femme noire qu'elle a
fait de région appelle la tête dorée
certains cadeaux a invité à l'est rien
robert six mois
oui
jacob
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous le dis pour une fois je
savais ce qui allait dans les gets you
pay je savais que la face noire était
dans la set j'ai voulu chamakh est admis
comme tu le savais je les ai sentis away
et bah écoutes je dois tu vas toi ton
chez lasserre cinq ans ayem à l'arrêt
[Applaudissements]
la chandelle au web
m c'est parti